and it's changing the world a lot it's
like having helpful friends on our
devices like Siri and Alexa who can
understand us really well also AI is
like a secret helper in the internet
World suggesting things we might like
when we watch shows or shop online but
it's not just about making life easy AI
is doing big things too for example in
healthcare it's finding new medicines
faster and helping doctors spot problems
early hair is also good for the planet
because it helps us save energy and
predict the weather more accurate the
future looks even better with AI making
a world more Innovative and efficient at
the same time it's like a kind of a
magic the more magical thing about this
field is the salary this field offers to
the professionals it's mind-blowing and
fascinating a Gartner study reports that
AI is an emerging field that will create
2.8 million jobs by 2025. so this video
will discuss the top five AI jobs in
2024 with highest salary this video will
help you in getting the answer to one of
the most sought after questions related
to artificial intelligence why you
should consider a career in this
exponentially growing feet but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them interesting then subscribe
to our YouTube channel because we bring
the best videos for you Dave also press
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply certifications provide the
most significant and well-defined part
to mastering any field on that note you
can also accelerate your career in Ai
and machine learning with a
comprehensive post-graduate program in
Ai and machine learning boost your
career with this Ai and machine learning
course delivered in collaboration with
the Purdue University and IBM learn
in-demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPT and many
you will receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones and different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical XP master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist helps you get noticed by the
leading company this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP neural
networks computer vision gns Keras
tensorflow and many more such skills
admission to this postgraduate program
in AIM machine learning requires two
plus years of work experience a
bachelor's degree with an average of 50
or higher marks basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics so
enroll now analog exciting Ai and
machine learning opportunities the link
is mentioned in the description box
below so without any further delay let's
start this video with what is artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence
refers to the development of computer
systems and software that can perform
tasks that typically require human
intelligence these tasks include
reasoning problem solving learning from
experience understanding natural
language recognizing patterns and making
decisions AI aims to create machines or
softwares that can mimic human cognitive
functions enabling them to perform tasks
with worrying level of complexity AI is
surely one of the most sought after
Industries for professionals looking for
a promising career and a lucrative
salary so let's talk about the top five
AI jobs with the highest salaries at
number five we have a computer vision
engineer a computer vision engineer is a
programmer skilled in creating software
using visual input sensors and
algorithms these systems can interpret
their environment as seen in
self-driving cars and facial recognition
computer vision Engineers uses languages
like C plus plus and python they work on
tasks like object detection emit
segmentation facial and gesture
recognition and scene comprehension
consequently the compensation packages
for computer vision Engineers have
become notably attractive according to
glassdo the average salary of a computer
vision engineer is hundred and fifty
five thousand dollars in the United
States and in India it's rupees 8 lakh
per annum serving as a significant
incentive for individuals venturing into
this domain
at number 4 we have software Engineers
software Engineers handle tasks from
design to deployment but it's rare to
find experts in All Phases they usually
specializes in specific areas this
specialization applies to AI software
Engineers too they work on various
applications including machine learning
inference learning NLP and intrusion
detection
covering different aspects of AI
development consequently decompensation
packages for software Engineers have
become notably attractive according to
Glassdoor the average salary of a
software engineer is one hundred and
forty thousand dollars in the United
States and in India it's rupees 9 lakh
per you know serving as a significant
incentive for individuals venturing into
this domain
moving on to number three we have
machine learning Engineers a machine
learning engineer creates and deploys
training algorithms and models which is
the most demanding part of machine
learning most machine learning Engineers
hold Advanced degrees in computer
science mathematics or statistics due to
the need for advanced math skills many
also pursue specialized master's degrees
or certifications in machine learning
deep learning on neural networks
consequently the compensation packages
for ML Engineers as well is notably
attractive according to glasdow the
average salary of a machine learning
engineer is 150 000 in the United States
and in India it goes up to 11 lakh
rupees per annum with additional cash
benefits at number 2 we have an AI
research scientist AI research
scientists often computer scientists
focuses on innovating a algorithms and
models
their duties include creating and
evaluating new AI models collaborating
in research publishing papers and
presenting ad conferences while
programming is a part of their work it's
just a portion unlike the tech
industry's openness to self-staught
programmers AIR research scientists need
strong backgrounds in computer science
mathematics and statistics consequently
the compensation packages for AI
research scientists have become notably
attractive according to glasdow the
average salary of an AIR research
scientist is 125 000 in the United
States
and rupees 21 lakhs per annum in India
with additional cash benefits and
finally at number one we have an AI
product manager an AI product manager is
much like other program managers they
oversee teams for AI product development
handling schedules and Milestones to do
this effectively they need to understand
AI components like hardware and
programming languages which helps them
support their teams creating AI apps
differs from web applications in
structure and development processes
consequently the compensation is the
highest for AI product managers in 2024.
according to glasdow the average salary
of an AI product manager is 190 000 in
the United States and in India it goes
around 26 lakh rupees per annum with
additional cash compensations
so these are the top five job rules you
should consider entering in 2024 so
let's go through the reasons why AI
individuals are paid so much the first
reason is surging demand AI is in high
demand across Industries due to its
potential for Innovation and
competitiveness leading to higher
salaries for Professionals in this field
specialized expertise a specialist
possesses unique skills in areas like
machine learning and data analysis
justifying their higher pay business
impact ai's transformative potential for
businesses results in higher
compensation for experts who help
Implement AI Solutions
Talent scarcity the shortage of
qualified AI professionals creates
intense competition among employers
driving up salaries and the last reason
is continuous learning and Innovation AI
experts are rewarded for staying updated
and Innovative in a rapidly evolving
field
with the growing demand for a expertise
skill professionals have opportunities
to boost their earnings by enhancing
their skills acquiring Advanced
education and gaining practical
experience
so let's dive into four effective
strategies to elevate your AI engineer's
salary enabling you to excel in a
competitive job market and negotiate
more favorable compensation the first
strategy is broaden your skill set
continuously expand your expertise in AI
related domains such as machine learning
deep learning natural language
processing and of course computer vision
stay up to date with the latest tools
Frameworks and algorithms by becoming an
expert in specific areas due to
exceptional Knowledge and Skills you can
command higher compensation pursue
Advanced education consider pursuing
Advanced degrees in AI or related fields
such as a Masters or a postgraduate
course higher levels of Education often
opens doors to higher paying career
opportunities Advanced degrees not only
showcase your commitment to the field
but also provide you with an extensive
knowledge and research experience
significantly boosting your earning
potential gain practical experience
engage in real world AI projects to
accumulate practical experience and
build a robust portfolio a explore
options such as internships
contributions to open source projects
and involvement in AI research
initiatives and the last strategy is
pursue industry recognized
certifications attain certifications
that are widely recognized in artificial
intelligence technology and framework
domain these certifications validate
your AI skills and competence
positioning you as a valuable asset for
companies adopting AI Solutions such
credentials gives you Competitive Edge
over other candidates and result in more
generous salary offers on that note do
check out the link mentioned in the
description below for postgraduate
program Nai and machine learning by
Purdue University and simply learn and
with that we have come to the end of
this video on top 5 AI jobs with the
highest salaries in 2024. I hope you
found it valuable and entertaining
please ask any questions about the
topics covered in this video in the
comment section below and the experts
will assist you in addressing your
problems as soon as possible thank you
so much for being here we'll see you
next time until then keep learning and
stay tuned to Simply learn for more
amazing updates
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel